well for decades the Bay Area has let
itself become a haven for vagrants at
the expense of the few normal people who
still live there
finally somebody had enough earlier this
month a man was videotaped gathering up
a vagrants belongings and throwing them
in the trash was on public property by
the way now that man has been charged
with second degree robbery and of course
the area remains the same hive of
needles and human wastes it has been for
years Rebecca Kaplan is an Oakland City
Council member and she joins us tonight
Rebecca thank you for coming on so this
story nice meeting me if I oh absolutely
my pleasure if I showed up on your front
lawn with a sleeping bag in a case of
vodka and sort of moved in to stay which
I may do would you be arrested for
trying to make me leave well I would
welcome you'd be happy to have that
conversation with you and hope we could
have dinner sometime
but I think more to the point the person
who threw the belongings in this case of
a homeless man into the lake and stole
somebody else's cell phone that person
would be prosecuted whether the person
they did that to was homeless or not
however as to the deeper solutions
tomorrow the City of Oakland will be
debating our budget and I will be
fighting for better solutions to
homelessness we need to be helping
people live in situations other than our
streets and sidewalks even while I a
brightly condemned this assault and
would condemn it no matter who it was
done to so go what is it what I mean it
just seems like the cards are kind of
stacked against normal people married
people with kids who have jobs kind of
like the backbone of America's people
actually built the country they're
having a tougher time living in your
state so they're leaving as you know
people get arrested for taking homeless
detrás trash off public property but
they don't get arrested for defecating
in public how does that work what's the
thinking behind that well certainly if
people want to volunteer to help clean
up our lake our creeks our public ways
we have volunteer opportunities we have
ways that people can help clean up and I
welcome that this was not an act of
cleaning up the lake this was stealing
someone's belongings and throwing them
on the boats
trashing nothing but wait wait a second
we have a ready-made group of people a
lot of them young with tons of time on
their hands we call them the homeless
why don't they clean up their crap why
are they the ones littering why aren't
they cleaning up actually it's
predominantly not the homeless people
that are littering we did a study in
about 85% of the illegal dumping is
coming from a variety of illegal sources
having nothing to do with the homeless
and so the illegal dumping or some of
this problem that we're fighting and
illegal is the work you're doing so
you're getting to the causes things will
get to take action on as well but still
why would you know any better places for
the homeless to be in other words it's
not enough to say where we don't want
people to go we need to provide the
places and I'm fighting for us to use
public land churches that have offered
to volunteer their sites to allow the
homeless to have places they can be
where they can get assistance where they
can get mattress social services and
turn their lives around while living in
places better than the sidewalk what
have you in the meantime
churches certainly have a lot of egos
well that's not I mean you didn't want
to but I'd be happy to remind us all
right I will I agree with that but let's
just the deeper questions because I know
that you want to why is it california is
so-called homeless problem is often
blamed on housing costs and as in most
liberal cities they're really high
because it's all rich people who live
there but Tokyo has even higher housing
prices and it has no homeless problem
what does Tokyo know that Oakland and
San Francisco don't know most other
democracies in the world devote a
significantly larger share of their
public funds to helping the homeless to
providing social services to provide
some Java programs no nope nope not true
the answer they don't have a ton of
broken families and drug problems in
Japan do you think maybe there's a
connection between the total
disintegration of the American family
and the fact that a lot of people are
living outside on heroin
we actually have a very sad situation of
families living outside we have people
living on the street especially not get
up and go to work every day and come
back and sleep I know that's true after
working all day because housing is so
scarce and so expensive and that's why
in our budget debate taking place
tomorrow night I'll be fighting for us
to do more to protect affordable housing
and to do more ok so it's really about
the other things I mean cuz they they
don't spend more money than you do on
the homeless they spend much less their
housing prices are higher I mean maybe
there's a solution there I don't know if
we're gonna solve it on the show cuz
we're almost out of time but have you
thought about that will you think about
it well most of the countries with the
less of this problem have universal
health care so people don't get pushed
into financial dire straits from a
health care cost but I also know right
that we don't look at that I'm sorry
we're out of time good thank you I hope
you'll come back any time it's great to
see you